please
all right hi everyone this is a
wolfram language design review about
spatial statistics
so we already had a bunch of spatial
statistics in 12
3 right or was it in 12-2 i think two
okay
um so
um if you want to i can give sort of a
bit up to what this is this part
the previous uh spatial statistics
its main objective was basically spatial
events
you know like trees
um the the distance and density of those
kinds of things
and models for how you you know we're
talking we're talking biological trees
here
yeah
and
you know stars and
particles things like that stuff this
time around
the main objective is basically
continuous functions
of uh you know of you know as function
of spatial locations
so think of elevation for instance
they'll think of ozone levels so think
of
mineral deposit layers or things like
that okay where you have partial
measurements and you would like to fill
in the missing data if you like
uh like spatial interpolation of some
kind yes exactly and the model
uh and so we've elected to not do
the basic you know a comprehensive model
where we have models for this but models
for this would be things like stochastic
partial differential equations and
things like that we've not done that but
we've done
the killer user use case which we think
is to take data and fill in the missing
values
with
you know interpolation or it's really an
approximation why aren't we calling it
spatial interpolate i mean predict is
because the problem is that it isn't
interpolation
it's not interpolation
you mean it doesn't hit the data points
right
it's not interpolation and i don't think
we should use interpolate for things
that doesn't interpolate but
just to be clear what we mean by that by
interpolate
you you mean hit the data points that
are given yeah the question is does this
hit the data points that are given or
not it does not okay
so it's making a function
that attempts to be a spatial
approximation of some kind
but it isn't
it's not
so
it's not an interpolation
i understand it's kind of like a fitted
function except even i mean a fitted
function
generally
well fitted function doesn't necessarily
hit the points
yes exactly
but the problem is that predictive
they're all examples of approximations
so is predict as an example i i know but
a predictor is a very specific machine
learning thing okay in our system okay
i really don't like using it here i mean
i think that it's let me know
fine
can we have a time series predict as
well
yeah let's also predict i mean actually
it's called forecast
okay but that's different okay which is
good because this is the predict brand
right
okay sorry so
okay so wait a minute the geodensity
plot we have geodensity part don't we
yeah or do we yeah but we really want to
use this function for that
underneath that it goes through
contortions to use what we have so
okay
so we should look at this page and and
most likely we will start pro we'll
start flowing in for a lot of our list
plotting functions to use this this kind
of function
okay
this is not working something is set up
wrong here can you just send me this
file please
it's a special predict
not prediction prediction
oh special predictor the the the
the guide page
oh the guide pages okay
there's a guide page spatial prediction
okay yeah go to the you know it's a good
it has links to everything
you know if you click on that other
thing it's actually going to work
because this apple search thing doesn't
work so good
which other thing is going to work click
on that qr or or whatever it's called
the open guide page button
you're gonna love it okay get used to
using it and you'll love it
okay
all right so
the basic point here is this is going to
be like an interpolating function
you're going to give it is it is it list
pairs is it x list x y
for the coordinate positions
it's location values
no no no no no no no what i'm asking is
when i have this function
and i use the function
yeah right
i'm so when you're using the function
yeah it takes it takes the list
yes right i mean spatial predict here
of
i don't even understand what any of this
is so
this special predict if i feed it
you know a particular lat long for
example yeah you got a value
okay but now how does it know it's
i see the the function originally
decides it's going to eat lat longs is
that right
yes
as opposed to eat for example pure
numerical coordinates yeah it can do
both okay okay fine
you know and it does like transformation
function if you have a list of points it
will it will um
compute you know listability across that
in a set of points that list the points
so what's the analog of this in time
series
what do you mean of what well what's the
analog of what this is doing in a time
series so in other words in a time
series i may have specific data points
and i want to interpolate the time
series how do i do it
i mean
time series literally interpolates on
its own
i mean it just does that that's what
time series does that's the definition
of time series and it literally use
interpolation okay so what why is this
why is what we're doing here
so what we want to do here so
interpolate doesn't work particularly
well so first of all interpolation
doesn't work particularly well when you
have sparse data that you often have in
the geo
situation okay so for the time series
you're saying it does work
because you know you know nothing
you don't have some background geometry
there is a value there's a whole set of
models called time series models
right that are similar to these
and time series forecast makes use of
those okay but so what i'm saying is
design wise we're not being consistent
here that is
you know armor models or whatever else
it is all these back end models
like one could imagine something where
you take the sparse time series data
right and just like you're saying
spatial predict here you could say
something like you know time series
predict
and you'd get a time series predictor
function or something or temporal
predictor function then it would all
work the same
yes one could imagine that
so let's think that through for a second
i mean so maybe one one question would
be i mean
one question would be if this basically
also encompasses the stuff you're
talking about with geo raster right
because then then you could imagine
having some object you know like you
have a time series object that's you
know
that's sort of a queryable interpolating
thing but i guess that i guess maybe a
question would be if you had some like
remotely sensed data or something like
that where you've got like millions of
points it's like a you know
five gigabytes so you know raster data
uh
is it at all practical to represent it
like this you know and have
interpolation and stuff like that or is
it just going to be super slow
roger were you in the geo-raster
conversation no
okay so you need you guys need to know
about that so you understand what the
point is the point is you've got
a
you've got an image that has been
sampled with a particular projection of
the earth because it's based on some
satellite that's looking at the earth in
some particular way
but
that you know it's a slant the satellite
as a slant angle for example
right but then the question is what is
the actual density
of
you know whatever they are on the on the
surface what's the actual area that has
this temperature on the surface of the
earth or something
do you get what i'm saying
yeah so i assume that it means that you
have geo coordinates that describes what
you sample is that the issue i mean it
was basically just geo-referenced
geo-referenced images yeah we got it
okay but i guess the question is i mean
is this basically just a better way of
representing geo-referenced images where
you know each pixel turns into a point
and you have interpolation and stuff
like that or will this just get
destroyed when you put that much data
into it
well i mean this can be made
it is fairly efficient
i don't know that we've sort of sent it
like gigabytes of stuff
but it and it can be made more efficient
if that's
you know that's i don't think it's been
designed for what you described like
gigabytes
um but it seems like we have to get
design consistency between the geo
raster functionality and this
well i don't know what
do you rush i know so okay so
where do we have uh who's somebody
isn't isn't it the main thing for geo
raster to have the meta information that
says what where the hell it is
no it's also this transformation stuff
i mean i think the point is you just
want to be able to you know you want to
be able to do things like okay you have
two geo rasters that maybe have that
sounds like just a data container that
needs to know where it is
no
no roger it needs to know why is it
called
where it is includes the projection
presumably right i mean i think it is
just a geo-referenced image but there's
a bunch of stuff that you want to be
able to do operations on them and
combine them and so on but the question
is whether or not that functionality can
basically just be encompassed by this
stuff here
i think not but i think they have to
dovetail together
yeah
so i mean
can one interpret a raster as a bunch of
points
i guess one could one could
it's just complicated and it's
not i mean it's like saying an image you
know we've got this concept of image
data which takes the image and turns it
into you know an array
and you know but the fact is there's a
huge amount of operation you know stuff
one does to images as images and
occasionally
you know in rare cases when we're once
doing an operation where it doesn't work
just with images you get the image data
and do the operation on the array
and i think the same will be true here
yeah
so i mean
that may be the the the api between
those things may simply be
that you can get from geo raster there's
got to be a way to get out of georasta
the pointless
that would be the same thing as spatial
point data right i mean there is a thing
that one can make this fundamentally
pretty damn efficient uh for instance
you do when you predict the value
you don't use
you know values that are very far away
uh you you you limit the region
you know over which i get
the the spatial dependence relationship
it's basically
if you build spatial data structure that
you only look at those points those are
the only things that are going to depend
that they're going to depend on
in a linear fashion
right but okay but so
[Music]
to me one of the things which we hadn't
thought of in talking about georasta is
being able to turn georaster into into
spatial point data
possibly just by feed spatial point data
a geo raster and it turns it into that
and vice versa
does that make sense
maybe who is who is taking notes here
that would be me uh i and i'll follow up
on all this
okay
um
i mean
if you just have a bunch of points and
you feed it to image what the hell is it
gonna do
um you know there might be two spars you
might have to have yourself you know
so it may not make sense
you're saying feeding spatial point data
to geo raster it might not be you might
be right right yeah although also i know
when we talked about georaster before we
did talk about having um
uh
because when when you have you know a
geo raster and you reproject it in the
new projection it might not be
rectangular so we're going to we're
talking about how there has to be some
sort of alpha channel you know where
we're not the whole the whole image
doesn't have to have data in it so maybe
there would be a way of doing it but
yeah
right but i think it's not particularly
natural if there's just a bunch of
points you know floating in the ocean
sure
um all right let's look at the design of
this thing itself
okay
um
i think that you tend to generate
rasters when you have like a satellite
that scans systematically
over an area
i mean often when you have drones you're
not necessarily doing that you can
follow all kinds of patterns and it
might not be as dense of a coverage
well you're saying there's a combination
thing which is a pathed geo raster so to
speak where where there's a swath of
data from a drone for example actually
interestingly the reading that you have
here is is i think satellite data but it
has these missing gaps you see that this
yeah yeah right
but most satellites when they go over
they make these sets of gaps and there's
even more pathological cases like i know
there's this like genocide
process right this is what's being
filled in here with this spatial
prediction function
okay so this is in fact a geo raster
type operation sort of yeah i mean the
data wasn't presented as a geo raster
but right but it could have been
i mean that picture there looks
quintessential geo-rastery
right
okay so so we clearly do have to merge
these two concepts
who's sponsoring ngo raster i mean where
did that come from uh the jose team
the geo team
okay he's working on dio and um i guess
brett also
is that right christopher do you
remember
do
silly i mean i i i i was sort of
interested in this and i wrote some
things i sent them to jose and there
were some meetings about it but i don't
really know what's happened
right well it was supposed to be an
active project exciting
project
um i'm sorry i haven't heard of it as an
active project yeah well i don't think
you would have done because nobody made
this connection
no but jose reports to me i should know
well fair enough yeah i mean i'm not i'm
not sure it's really being
also
i mean the the design i sent was also
like has problems it's like so so it's
not no no but we had a meeting where we
actually made progress on the design and
i thought we had a plan
to do this
i mean i think we we spent i i don't
think we resolved like
enough that there that it could be like
imminently somebody see if jose is it
could be found we can just ask him
no nobody can do that okay
i'll do it
[Music]
okay
okay so let's take a look here
at what this does although it's clearly
that the design is going to have to be
merged with this other idea
so we probably won't make it for 2013
then
probably not
pity we didn't review this earlier
i mean if we're lucky this will be
simple to merge
okay so this thing here
is what this is a the spatial point
process
generates
there's no processes i i know i know i
know what spatial point process
generates
is some spatial point data which this
should be able to eat correct
and this is simply a a smaller you know
in a lighted version of the space no
correct no there's no continuous value
of tree locations above any point in
space
you know there's no continuous
you misunderstood i mean they're
different things events are not the same
as continuous
you know surface
okay what is this this is special point
data represents such a set of points
this has values associated points yes
right exactly fine what is the analog
okay what's the analog
so it's a function on the points spatial
point process is just points themselves
yes what's the analog for spatial point
data of something which has values at
the points
the the the the
the value that they're at points are
called annotations in that case and they
are things like
you know tree species
you know we don't really
model that
particularly
okay so wait a minute so so what we've
got here you know for example in a time
series we can imagine having categorical
data
although i don't think we deal with that
well right now
right
but so what you're saying is that i mean
just like a function of a graph right
now we do in this kind of slightly
cruddy way of having annotations of
vertices
right it's not karate
graphs or networks are more general
things than just the mathematical graphs
they represent other objects and that's
what annotations are for you can have
annotations on nodes and edges converges
and edges but but fine but so it's right
here
it's like the
the way to do it all right fair enough
okay but although the support i mean the
question of what support
you know a function on a graph
what do you mean by a function on a
graph what the hell do you mean i don't
know what you mean well okay
you're right it could be nodes it could
be edges i don't know what you mean by a
function on a graph what does it okay
for example if you compute you know
let's say you have a um
and my graph and my graph is
is has a very special meaning you know
it's uh
i don't know it's a block diagram so
what's a function on a block diagram
okay look the okay
the issue is
there's some base space there's some
values
and you're right that there are
different ways to define the base space
associated with the graph
in the case that you're doing it looking
at here the base space is a little bit
more straightforward it's a bunch of
points in you know d-dimensional space
basically yeah or geo geospatial space
geospace
okay but but so my question is
in the analog of okay with spatial point
data
you're saying that like on a graph the
way you associate
values
with which might be categorical or might
be continuous
values or numerical
values with points is through
annotations is that correct yes it is
okay
so it's a slightly you know that's
slightly weird because in time series
for example it is not not the case you
could do an analogous thing you could
take the time of the date objects and
and put annotations on them but instead
in time series we actually have the idea
that there's a mapping from time to
value
yeah it's like a function of time i know
that this is like a function of space
but a continuous function i
make that absolutely clear i got it but
what i'm saying is there's two different
representations that we are using for
this no one is still allow for
wait a second wait a second i'm saying
in the case of time series okay one
thing i could imagine doing
is i mean right now we have something
which maps
time value time point
to value at that point
right that's correct okay so now
what we could also imagine doing
syntactically
is saying there's an annotation for that
time point
that stores the value which is what you
say you're doing in special point data
but that's discrete that's the different
things
but this unique collection of points
okay
i understand but you're using that the
whole point is spatial predict is
attempting to create a continuous
function from those discrete values just
like time series when you actually
construct it does not start from a
continuous function it starts from a
bunch of discrete values which are then
interpolated that's all fine that's all
fine but the model that you should think
in terms of is something continuous
it doesn't matter i'm i'm saying i'm
just talking about how you enter the
data i'm saying one but then you
conflate the next minute you conflate
two things and then we're in a big mess
and now we don't know what which things
do you think you're conflating you're
like you're conflating events
and continuous things like an earthquake
it's not this there's like nothing i i
know eventually series and time series
are different i got it
so the the special point data was
designed as a somewhat general container
and it has the the possibility to add
annotations because in the discrete for
example cases we talk about the three
species you would like to annotate what
species growing at which location but
also you know it might be extended to
store some values which may come from
continuous field but we make no
assumptions on what the values are so
what the annotations are and that's how
it differs from the time series
so so we don't have per se
um a container that would correspond to
the time series in a spatial case i got
this point so what we do we just have
the locations and values
and it may happen that we're gonna use
you know some storage that a special
point data in you know to to store this
type of you know data but it's not
automatically understood as a continuous
i i think i understood this okay okay so
yeah just just to be clear you know for
example you've got trees they've got
heights right is there a height field
for the trees well you might want to
think of their being as or you might not
want to think of that being
yeah
there are two types of okay so in that
field i'm sorry sorry i shouldn't use
the name field in that domain
okay there are two types of annotations
okay and they're not called annotations
it's something that we've invented um
there are things that things depend on
and they usually call covariates so for
instance
the elevation
is something that depends on how
frequently tree grows like at very high
elevations there isn't many trees
growing
okay so that that's something that you
can use then to model or you know that
sort of depends on that now the output
side so that's like the input side for
for that stuff the output side might be
exactly what we talked about like the
the species which is sort of something
discrete or its height or actually when
you start reading these books diameter
at breast height seemed to be like the
killer
annotation to store
okay because people want to do it's all
started with
taxation and so
uh resource estimates for taxation
purposes of forests
okay who's taxing forests
the germans were pioneers and the swedes
were pioneers
but i think everybody forest i think
everybody taxes i bet the uk taxes
forest
okay maybe that was you know the whole
robin hood thing was all about taxation
of trees who knows
well you need to estimate that the
resources there
okay in any case
so you need to count them
so it's the basic question here just
just whether or not
whether or not you have a function where
you give it the locations and values and
you get out the interpolated you know
value
or whether you have a container where
you put in all this stuff and then it
sits there and then you query it later
yeah that basically if we if yeah if we
had bit if we had built
if we had built the models we would have
simulated and generated data in which
case we would have a strong interest in
building a container
that container would have itself been
probably useful because it could support
a bunch of spatial query like operations
and be very efficient for that but we
haven't built it because we don't need
it right now
okay hold on so let's jose is now here
and jose probably doesn't know why he's
here but this is a collision with jio
rasta
okay can you remind us or point us to
design documents about your rasta
um the only design document we had is
the notebook that christopher sent
and
then we talked about it further right
yes yes but based on on that notebook so
we didn't it's a it's a discussion we
started but we couldn't conclude in in a
meeting we had so
still pending okay continue but so
the basic concept was
this is a block of values
that have been
uh that have a particular geo
that have a mapping to
uh the geo-based space so to speak is
that correct is that the basic concept
in the end
yes the original idea was to have that
for images and then we started
discussing to extend it to other
data like quantity arrays of elevations
or
right okay so that's where we intersect
with this
right so the difference i think is the
following
a quantity array or or an image
is
you know necessarily rectangularized
data
in some sense in some coordinate system
whereas what you're doing here is every
tree for itself so to speak now this
isn't trees again i i'm just joking i'm
i'm you understand every point for
itself
right did you know someone saying that
the point can be any way you want right
right and the point can be an elevation
i mean the value i i i know i know i
know the point that i'm making is and we
got too many points running around here
but the
okay i'm using trees to concretify this
and i mean like conifers those kinds of
trees you know right but that was a bad
example
um okay all right fine but but what i'm
saying is
that imagine a tree field
in which the trees are all arranged in a
you know in a coordinate grid no you're
still confused okay so i thought no i'm
not confused yes i'm not confused i'm
sorry stephen you are confused
um
what would be related to trees that is
relevant in this case and then the
raster case would be something like tree
density
i got it i got it i'm not i i was it was
a bad example okay it is a fine example
all right okay all right let's say
you know let's say the intensity of
color in some satellite image or
something like this but the point about
it is what i'm saying is there
one thing is there is an array
and you've got a bunch of values in the
array okay now you could disembody a
single pixel and you could say i'm just
going to talk about that pixel with its
with its center location and the value
of that pixel as a disembodied pixel
floating around
right without without it being embedded
in this essentially coordinate grid
array yeah except that there are two
models of how images work
one is that this is sort of basically
like a piecewise constant value over the
pixel square
yep um the other one is that you
associate value with corners
i don't know
okay i understand that they're going to
be different ways to do it i'm just
trying to understand the design
correspondence between this essentially
point data that you have here
and this notion of array data that we've
been talking about for geo raster sure
okay so i think
maybe these two two issues sort of
collide in a virtuous way right because
basically okay so so maybe this function
spatial predict it can it can take the
things it currently takes or takes you
know location value rules and then maybe
if we decide later to create this
container for location value rules it
could also take that and then it could
also take a geo raster if those exist
right so that basically you know this
function is just a and you know
right i mean so it's fine that we might
have two different ways of representing
you know geo-raster data versus these
you know value
i'm beginning to agree with you i mean
i'm beginning to agree and i think that
the the difference is the field versus
the trees as opposed to the forest
versus the trees uh if if you
okay so confused
what i mean
christopher's right okay
but you're still confused i'm not
confused i'm just using bad analogies i
think different trees the trees are only
relevant for the spatial point what's it
called spatial point data it's not
relevant for either geo-raster or this
both of these assume it's a continuous
function yes i i understand i agree
that's what i'm saying i'm
that you're never mind yes i think i
understand
right it's a one of them is a continuous
function sampled on a grid and the other
is something where the sample values are
at random points
yes
okay where the continuous function there
is a function in the background but we
just know its values on a grid not
necessarily not necessarily on the grid
so that's also where this this is was
taking oh i know you have irregular
sampling no no obviously no no no no no
the geo raster case is the grid case
right that's what i'm saying yes yes
your case is you can have points
wherever you choose
correct
in particular that can be on a grid
in particular for example yes but and
that in that case there will be overlap
between what you can do with this sort
of and what we can do with geo raster
except there will be a difference
because as you say like the pixel values
it could be the center of the pixel it
could be the corners of the pixel it
could be a bunch of other things in this
case it's like there is a point at these
coordinate positions and it has this
value in the other case it's somehow
it's you know representing a
discretization of a continuous field
where
you know it goes from cell to cell so to
speak
i think the key question here is whether
there is a value that can be assigned to
any point
how do you get to that value doesn't
matter well it's like time series versus
event series exactly yes yeah
okay all right okay i think we actually
converged on something reasonable here
okay
so i see various comments in our
live stream here sandra is commenting
fluid dynamics the data location is
random and changing over time yeah well
that's a different issue is there is the
merging of time series and spatial
yes so this doesn't do
so so ultimately and we're just getting
to this now called video when you want
to look at spatial temporal things
yes uh but this one doesn't do spatial
temporal but yes that would be the
extension
everything can change over time
and over space why is what's the
difference between three dimensions and
i mean what's the difference between a
three-dimensional thing like this oh i
see because the difference is that
things have their their world line so to
speak that a thing a point typically
will just evolve over time whereas a
three-dimensional data set will have
different random points in the z
direction so to speak as opposed to
continuity in the t direction
that makes sense the big thing in
statistics and generally uh with time is
that in particular in statistics you
would like it to be causal in time
meaning it only depends on its history
it doesn't depend on its future
so if you want to predict something you
don't want to necessarily i understand
but i think there's a different point
which is the one i was making which is
that the the the chances are
you know there is in the case of 3d
right you might very well have a
situation where they're a bunch of
random i don't know buoys on an ocean
floating around and their position
is
uh
you know their position is is
you know they're like a spatial point
data in terms of position but then as a
function of time those things don't
spontaneously disappear and
spontaneously appear so to speak
so there's a different kind of
continuity there i mean yeah i mean this
this this thing spatial predict works
fine in 1d 2d 3d and i understand but
but but it's not dealing with the thing
i just said
namely
it's done not dealing with evolution in
time no no it's not dealing with the
fact that there's as far as it's
concerned every time slice
is a completely new story
it's not dealing with the idea that that
some point should be i mean
elevation sort of changes over time most
of the time we have like a
a
we we think of it as static not evolving
over time so much
sure i understand yeah right
unless it's over geological times which
is a different story right um
sandra is asking about uh large data and
out of core operations different meeting
it's a thing actively being talked about
but it's different discussion
okay sounded common sense parental fluid
flow fields one often has holes or
corners cut off because there's a
boundary or no laser coverage so that's
very similar presumably to the
geo-raster case
where the satellite could have you know
had i don't know what happens to
satellites that cause them to have only
a certain region covered
uh
most comments about craiging which is
which is the underlying method being
used this is krieging okay so this is
south african mining engineer krieger
oh okay okay
and so the terminology originally that
he was interested in gold mining so
the terminology for that variance the
the the measurement variance
it was called a a nugget
we decided to not introduce the nugget
terminology right but nugget was what
because they were doing gold mining yes
yes okay
um
amenities on our livestream comments
that
slash and burn agriculture was the main
way swedes and germans used to do
agriculture they used the ash from the
trees as potash fertilizer so forests
were just farmland
okay who says that
person on a live stream
i don't know
i mean yes
historically
no no they they would they were doing a
lot of burning yes uh but but but they
were actually sort of exporting the
trees to countries like the uk who
didn't who would um you know who'd
already cut down their trees a thousand
years earlier well you know
they cut them down pretty early so yeah
and so they would make coke and other
things and export it to
um
to britain
um okay
uh ethan is a commenting moral
explanation interpolate we
discuss that it can't be interpolated as
such but i don't think predictions right
would either
um
let's see
okay so let's come back to this design
okay so what you what it's eating is
these things which might one day be
some i mean
you know what would happen if you fed
spatial point data a location value pair
like this would it convert it into some
kind of annotation
thing or not
um this doesn't eat spatial point data
just because we don't know if the
annotations you know are continuous or i
think he asked the other way around what
if you set that input to spatial point
data right why can't it construct
annotations from that input
uh it can from the second one
why not from the first one
for convenience i would say and the fact
that we would like to have the the you
know the regularity in that in that way
in creation so that the length of the
annotations
um is the same so the thing is that
we're looking at the annotations uh uh
what's the word for this
as the whole set so uh
all configuration has annotations and
note that the single point so it say
that
you can have three annotations on one
point and four annotations my other
point we do not allow that so i don't
understand
that this is not that this is saying
location value so why isn't it the case
that you can turn that into a spatial
point data with a particular value
annotation at every point interior
decree yes not in maybe not in exactly
the same syntax but in the idea yes i
know but that's my point my point is if
you feed i'm trying to make syntax
compatibility between these various
functions right
so you know you've got data in the form
of location value and now you want to
use do spatial statistics of the kind
that we do with spatial point data on
that data
i'm just saying it should it should not
only work in whatever spatial predict
gets called but it should also work
through spatial you know in whatever
space whatever space makes sense yes
okay all right fine okay
then but then conversely
it's less obvious if you feed special
point data to spatial predict
it doesn't know which of the annotations
is supposed to be the value value so to
speak
and that's why we don't automatically
work
i know so let's think about that for a
second because how would you process
spatial point data so that it can be fed
to a thing that is basically looking for
a spatial field
my question so given special point data
which has where there's four values
associated with every point in the
spatial point data now i want to say i
want to do i mean it's not obvious to me
that i shouldn't just that spatial
prediction interpolate effectively all
of them
crying all of them
why doesn't it do that
some of them might be categorical
right
but but if it isn't categorical why
doesn't it just as a courtesy why didn't
you just do it
and return to you i mean what it's going
to return is this thing which is no
longer what is what is this thing it's
it's it's a spatial prediction function
right predictor function predictive
function okay so but but that so my
point is you either got to be able to
slice off okay i don't know whether it's
useful to take spatial point data and
cry all of the variables
or all of the annotation values or
whether you want to slice off a
particular annotation value and then
make that into a field like this
so so maybe okay a question about about
crying all of them though i mean can you
can the values here be multi-dimensional
or do they just have to be a single
value
in spatial predict
this is for this colors
scholar field
so if you if you if you give if you give
the vector it's going to be treated as
an independent input
okay so so if there was some mechanism
for a quote-unquote crying all of the
variables i mean that would correspond
to multiple calls to spatial predict
basically right right now okay so ethan
is asking can this handle imputing wind
vector data across the globe
a reasonable question yes
but you just said it was scalars gosha
well yes but if you cheat every every
component on the on a vector
individually then you can you can create
the component wise
that's again that's three calls to
spatial predict right
yeah yeah
but but so how would you represent that
so if you've got the wind data how do we
represent the wind data right now
if you say
uh what do we call it actually
it's the wind data and you can query
speed
for example so you could you could do
the the field of the wind speed
okay
hold on
there are two things and the first thing
is there's this geo vector but that's
maybe a more complicated story
supporting joe vector's values here it's
not totally clear what that would mean
maybe
but but then um
but separately i mean
given that it seems like okay it's
reasonable to sort of do these component
wise crying is there a particular reason
not to support you know
a vector inside the the value field in
spatial predict
right so you see you could just make one
call and maybe it internally it makes
into three calls but
do you understand what i'm saying
right and then return it back to value
function but
yeah
that's the idea
um
all
right
go go ahead go ahead what were you
saying
well i mean i i i just didn't hear
really responsible yeah i think it could
i think it could it just doesn't right
now
okay um
that would then return a vector-valued
function
uh although
yeah
there's some trickiness
yeah
let's think about that a little bit the
question is how different are the
components how you know dramatically
different are they
in their spatial dependence right and
the question is do you have a cross
component dependence because right now
no but they wouldn't model that okay
right it wouldn't model that that's
that's out of scope that would be a
different project
so that's what i'm just saying that it's
go doing component wise and so you don't
look this as a as a but it would still
be a service to the user to automate
that okay just so what what christopher
and steven sort of points out is like if
someone has vector data why should i
have to split it and do it myself twice
why don't we do it
right
right yeah that that's okay fine so then
the values here could be vectors
yes and and then although it is done
component wise but it can be any arrays
then you know might as well be any array
right well while we're adding things it
could also be an association maybe
yes that's true
yeah that's true if it's if it's got
numerical values why not
okay so let's um how do you
yeah
where do you want to put association i'm
sorry i'm confused i don't yeah it's
just well i mean i'm just saying i mean
i mean it's a question there's sort of
convenience things but like for the
values there right but i don't know what
would you get from the output
association at each point yes yeah you'd
get an association
yes i mean just in the same sense that
you know it's just you're just naming
the indices in the background
yeah yeah i guess not i guess that could
work too
um richard on our live stream is talking
about co-craiging which i don't know
what it is
but do you guys know about that what is
that
and what's the variant apparently of the
ordinary operation yes
it's when
it's something that we don't support yet
or intend to uh
it's essentially
exploiting possible having a call
having spatial dependence between the
different values in the
in the vector that we're doing okay so
this is this is the difference between
the the
component wise and some kind of
covariance
yes
between those okay fine so that's
something we're not dealing with yet
um okay let's go back to this main
design maybe sorry just as a quick
question though i mean if we did end up
supporting that i mean maybe there could
be a method option that specifies
whether you're doing it component-wise
or with the
the co-crying or covariate cracking
method
right i mean i just if we if we add the
support for putting vectors in it would
be
silly if then that makes it so we can't
add like any more proper way of
supporting vectors and criteria right i
agree i mean we should just change the
method basically if there's if we can do
it taking account of the fact that they
genuinely are vectors all right let's
let's go look at this
this um this thing okay
special chat model
special noise variants
okay so those don't sound like options
to me they sound like things you would
get out what's the analog in in time
series
of those kinds of kind of well okay look
we've we've basically got
if i'm not this is intended to be that
you can use it without specifying
anything no i realized that okay then
these are drill down capabilities when
you do want to specify things
i get it i understand i'm talking about
their names only that's all i'm talking
about but let's let's talk about the
main name special predict okay okay so
in the world of spatial statistics we've
got
so okay what should we call this this is
supposed to return a thing what what
does time series forecast this this is
this is a different branch of spatial
stuff these are the two main branches
the the previous one that we dealt with
and now this one these are the two
branches
i mean
points and fields in some sense yes
okay you got it right
i i had that a long time ago roger i
just got we were confused with trees
okay anyway
um
okay
the question is
what on earth do we call this function
and it really shouldn't be called
predict
spatial forecast
that's horrible that sounds like a
weather forecast that's why we well
that's why we
chose this okay so hold on i understand
but i don't think it's the right name i
mean arguably i mean
are arguably what it's doing is is for
the most part it's interpolation
i know but they're they're objecting
yeah i know but also the function
predict is also arguably doing
interpolation with many of its methods
or things you could call interpolation
so i don't know i mean i think it's like
i think you could argue that
the methods are probably very similar to
predict but it's just that calling it
predict maybe gives it a bit of a
machine learning it does we really don't
want to do that predict is crystal bally
and this is much more
interpolationy
no i mean it's the same damn predict
theory
same theory okay
look we can't call it predict that is a
machine learning brand unless we expect
we're going to use machine learning
stuff okay so that's a question
is is the future of this
is machine learning useful for this
it might be in the future now
not really
yeah not really right now
but okay
what do other people think i mean you
see okay so what are some other names we
could imagine here
i mean this is
um
ethan is suggesting
okay
uh spatial value impute
values horrible that's horrible
and it isn't it's also wrong
when you do the imputation of values you
do stochastic simulation
this is doing expectation
effectively the other way around
okay
what's some other words here
okay again what is this doing it's
taking a bunch of spatial values i mean
i have to say the word i would use to
describe this is interpolation
and it's trying to figure out for you
what
uh you know what the value is
but interpolation by definition requires
you that the resulting function goes
through the data points
right so
that would be a very very very very
special case for this i know i realized
that i realized the value estimate
instead of impute which is a word that
is a little bit more pretentious
a special value estimate
even though it's provost
that's a meaning
um
so wait a minute this is
you can give
like predict you could give an actual
you could give
the
sort of data and then you give a
specific value to get a prediction or
you can get a prediction function out is
that correct
no you get the prediction function out
okay that's not good enough because what
we do look look all these functions have
a particular form they take data and we
can say for that data if you just we can
add that okay we can't hand that it's
not particularly important i know it's
not particularly important but it is
very very inefficient
i understand all of those things
but for consistency with our other
functions we should be doing that
well it's like nearest and so on does
that
so
okay
okay
so the the thing is that the the
imperative term spatial predict
right
is
that imperative term essentially
requires for it to be meaningful a form
like this as opposed to a noun form
which is what you would expect
if you are just producing a thing that
will then be applied to data am i making
sense
okay so you want to call it prediction
instead of predict no no no i'm saying
if you say that it is so useless
to have the single value thing here
right
yeah then it is possible that we can
have a name that is the noun form
that returns the predictor function
or whatever it's called right that
that then we have a slightly different
name space
if we say predict it's got to work like
predict where you give it the data and
you say where you want it to predict for
okay even though that isn't do you have
a suggestion for a noun form no i don't
i don't i'm just saying that that allows
us a little bit more freedom and what we
i mean you know you could call it a
spatial estimation
for spatial estimator or something
or spatial estimate i mean which you
might read a spatial estimate
but spatial
is that crazy is spatial estimate crazy
for the function it's not totally crazy
wouldn't seem super intuitive to me but
it's not totally crazy
okay
see one point about predict that i also
don't like
is that predict is for the future so to
speak
in some sense whereas what this is much
more like that the typical use of this
will be much more like the typical use
of interpolation
that is just filling in data
whereas predict is usually i've got
these things and it's like what's going
to happen in the future that's not what
this is about oh it's just your
intuition is not there yet for spatial
stuff for spatial stuff
you predict the stuff that you don't
know
well
you could call it prediction but look a
lot of the use of this will just be i've
got this field of things i want to fill
in the field
yeah right but that's different from
predict predict is future
predict
say in advance
right which is different from fill in
which is the interpolation kind of idea
stuff that's already there i mean you
know just sort of fill in around stuff
we already know sure
i think spatial estimate is not terrible
um
uh
let's see let's take a look at these
other names i mean that would be my my
first choice here right now maybe we can
do better okay um
the okay so then it becomes a spatial
estimation function
for the uh for the actual
you know or spatial estimator function
estimator function probably is that
right
estimator i think yeah okay spatial
estimator function
okay now um okay so these are these
different
what is this is that an actual function
there
yeah so variogram is the thing that
tracks the spatial dependence and that's
the
that's the core of this function if you
like
this explains
the whole story there and this one
this is a big this is a big complicated
function
and roughly what it's doing is what it's
it's taking roughly speaking
it gives yeah there's a whole model
world
so what it's doing is it's fitting one
of those models of how the variogram
behaves okay
and that gets you a robust
uh estimator
spatial estimator function
of how things behave nearby
if we go up if we go a little slower i
can explain more along the way you know
what i think we're going to run out of
time here this looks like this is a
quite complicated thing to understand
it is um
i mean not really but
it takes more than two minutes
right okay what is bin variogram
bin varigram is basically like a sample
variogram it's it's a way to
compute sort of a kind of a rough
version of it
unfortunately
it's it doesn't result in a legal
variogram but it's still a an important
indicator
of what your data is like the spatial
extent of dependence
okay
but so what's happening here so the bin
variogram kind of uses as an initial
estimator that goes into this model
fitter
which i'm saying that
that snaps up the quality of the
underlying bariogram model
so it becomes a legal variogram and that
can actually be used in that spatial
prediction function this predictor
function
what does a variogram what does model
variogram return
it returns a bariogram function
which means what it's a function that
can be evaluated at different points
and this is think of this as uh
uh what do you call it when you have um
um
i'm sorry it's a spatial estimate it's
like a kernel function of sorts
yeah uh it like encodes the dependence
but see this
this this this doesn't look different in
different directions so it's um what do
you call it when it's the same way in
every direction
so this is an isotropic model so this is
the radial dependence
and how does that relate to those all
those radial
functions for spatial point data
what that what are those called the the
two the endpoint correlation
what is it called um per correlation but
that's different
so the the the per correlation is you
know that that relates to the
probability of finding points within a
certain distance
you're looking at the values so
basically what for example the bin bin
variogram does it beans per distance so
you're looking at all the points which
are distance given by this beam so say
whatever 10 plus minus epsilon meters or
something like that and then you look at
the values at this point and you compute
the variance covariance between the
points to see you know you're looking at
the the differences between the values
bariogram and var co-variance is roughly
this spatial covariance is roughly the
same thing the sort of one minus the
other right they are related and the
idea is that if you have this models it
it shows you how fast the spatial
dependence wanes off in what shape so
that when you move away from you know
when you increase the distance between
the points and that's what the what what
the model variogram variogram function
is it models you the the dependence the
variation really between the points so
you see that the variogram function
increases with distance because it
measures the variation between the
points
so the farther you go the bigger the
variation and in in usual
you know data field it's going to be the
the sample variance of of your points of
your data
but so
so just to understand so the two-point
correlation function were i to have
a spatial
a field of points so to speak that was
just a grid
right then the then the pair correlation
function
i see that's just the presence of those
points independent of value this is
looking at the correlation of values
between neighboring points right yes and
also you know as you keep in mind that
you can have
this underlying locations you know they
can be controlled and while we're
looking at the per correlation g and all
the statistics there this
is yeah okay but so my question here is
and then we should wrap for for now and
we should have an ex another one of
these
um
the uh but um my question here
is
you know this concept of
a
you know
a correlation function in a in a scalar
field
seems like a more general concept than
this
you know
i mean i've never heard of a very well i
have i've heard of it i didn't know what
it was this variogram idea
but the concept
of a
correlation function a scalar field
i mean at least in the physics world
there are plenty of places where that
appears
yeah
coverings function correlation function
etc right so my question is in terms of
naming if we say variogram that's
spatial statistics land
yes
and the question is is this i mean
you know is the core operation here
really a spatial statistics land thing
or is it something more basic about a
scalar field about a sampled scalar
field basically
i mean
when we first started i really didn't
want to introduce i really wanted to
have covariance function
you know a spatial covariance function
the problem is that
it
this one
they can't the covariance function can't
quite represent everything the variogram
can represent
that's why did spatial statistics folks
landed here
now although sometimes we have functions
which are named for their primary
you know the primary conceptual thing
and then we have an extension
yeah so to speak i mean i don't think
that's crazy i think it's better to have
a function which is named for what its
primary conceptual idea
with an extension
than to have a function that is named
for some bizarre extended form that is
not really related to the no i mean but
it's it's it's it isn't a covariance
function here you know it's it's as i
said they're related but it's not the
same
this is a measure of variation right so
hence the variogram because it's the
measure of variation well maybe we
should also then maybe maybe the point
is that we also should have
um the uh covariance function
uh not now
um
you know some uh
live stream is asking about can we
okay this would be a good exercise
okay that's
you know what that is
right that is projected i don't know
what that projection is what is that
projection that's a that's a projection
of the sky obviously
that's small why there
astronomers just can't find it
okay and which is something presumably
in our astro
i mean
how would we take in that data and do
anything with it
well it's the same situation as in geo
we have the position
containers but not the field containers
yep
okay okay fine but but then for example
your spatial statistics stuff should
allow one to get
i mean that should allow one to do
computations on this data is that a true
statement
yeah
but we need sort of the the question is
what are the positions are they they're
going to be astropositioned then
presumably the the future astroposition
so then it needs a small extension to
work with those
right but then this correlation function
thing
this is i mean you know people try to
compute correlation functions here
because they might actually be
you know the correlations of quantum
fields from long ago so to speak
and it should be the case if i'm not
mistaken and maybe jose can unscramble
this for a second i mean
it should be the case that that
correlation function and the correlation
function you're talking about here with
your variograms are essentially the same
thing
i i think so i mean they support already
geo position so this would be just
no i understand but i'm the point i'm
making jose is that the correlation
function as in expected value of you
know field at x and field at x plus
delta
right that's the you know that's the
that's the notion of a correlation
function
and
what is the relationship of the you know
that averaged over that the expectation
value of you know a of x a of x plus
delta
right
and
i think that is similar to what you're
doing with this variagram am i mistaken
or not
you're not mistaken
yeah it's it's it's similar yeah i mean
the correlation is a function of
variogram and the variance if the field
is stationary will be stationary
she doesn't have so i i would strongly
argue that it's worth having a function
even if you have the variogram thing
it's worth having a function called
spatial correlation or some such other
some such other name
that just gives you that correlation
function
i mean i would have thought
okay so in in that world
you know in the physics world the
endpoint correlation function is of
interest
that is
you know the correlation function with a
with you know
you know a of x say x plus delta times a
of x plus delta prime that's the
three-point correlation function does
that have an analog in variograms no no
okay
i mean that that's another thing that is
that is interesting to compute
okay we should we should um pick this up
in another meeting
um
all right i need to go
uh good stuff we'll schedule one more of
this yes
this is this is a lot of stuff but um
one more time and i'm sure that it will
feel much more yeah well that's fine i
mean this will nail this in another hour
yeah um
sounds good okay sounds good